on va démarrer
et Laurence Rossignol va nous rejoindre
dès qu'elle le pourra elle est dans les
transports c'est toujours compliqué les
transports le matin bien écoutez madame
monsieur mes chers collègues la santé
des femmes est un enjeu majeur qui
intéresse de nombreux sénatrices et
sénateurs au sein de notre délégation
c'est pourquoi nous avons nommé début
octobre 4 rapporteurs afin d'explorer
cette thématique de travail Annick Jake
mais qui est avec nous Marie-Pierre
Richer et Laurence Rossignol et Laurence
Cohen qui vont nous rejoindre un travail
important a déjà été mené par le Haut
Conseil à l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes le H&E qui a publié en
décembre 2020 un rapport intitulé
prendre en compte le sexe et le genre
pour mieux soigner un enjeu de santé
publique nous ne pouvions donc pas
entamer nos travaux sans entendre des
représentants du H&E nous sommes très
heureux d'accueillir ce matin Gilles
Lazimi co-président de la commission
santé droits sexuel et reproductif du
HC1 et Catherine Vidal membre de cette
même commission et auteur du rapport que
j'évoquais à l'instant bienvenue à tous
les deux ce matin je vous souhaite à
tous les deux donc de la bienvenue et je
on va vous écouter dans quelques minutes
nous vous laisserons nous présenter les
grands enseignements de votre rapport
ainsi que les suites qui ont pu être
donnés aux recommandations deux ans
après sa publication vous pointiez
notamment dans votre rapport un sous
diagnostic chez les femmes des maladies
cardiovasculaires des troubles du
spectre autistique ou encore de
l'endométriose avez-vous constaté des
progrès en la matière vous indiquez à
contrario que certaines pathologies sont
malheureusement davantage associés aux
femmes
les femmes souffrent ainsi deux fois
plus de dépression que les hommes les
facteurs de risque de dépression liés au
contexte socio-économique précarité
charge mentale violence affectant notre
davantage les femmes la prise en charge
des dépressions des tentatives de
suicide des troubles de l'alimentation
des addictions et de la santé mentale de
façon plus générale nous semble un sujet
à ne pas négliger que pouvez-vous que
pouvez-vous nous dire de cette prise en
charge aujourd'hui vous semble-t-elle
satisfaisante s'agissant des politiques
de prévention qu'elle devrait être selon
vous les principaux programmes à
destination des femmes vous avez salué
une amélioration de la prévention et de
la prise en charge des cancers du sein
et du col de l'utérus cependant nous
savons notamment que la couverture
vaccinale contre le papillone ma virus
reste à ce jour insuffisante nous nous
intéresserons également à la place des
femmes dans les recherches cliniques et
biomédicales
nous nous réjouissons avec vous qui n'y
est plus désormais de sous-repression
des femmes au sein des essais cliniques
pour autant il nous semble que ce n'est
pas le seul sujet tous les grands
scandales depuis 60 ans ont concernait
des médicaments et traitements destinés
principalement aux femmes
c'est une triste réalité en
médiator
distillent
l'évothyrox toutes ces substances c'est
vrai sont
associés souvent aux femmes avez-vous pu
explorer la question du financement et
de la production de médicaments à
destination des femmes ou en est-on de
la recherche sur l'impact des
perturbateurs endocriniens en
particulier sur la fertilité des femmes
et sur les traitements hormonaux à
destination des femmes enfin vous nous
direz quels sont les sujets que vous
n'avez pas pu ou pas souhaiter
développer au sein de votre apport
estimez-vous qu'il existe des angles
morts qui mériteraient aujourd'hui
d'être approfondie
donc bienvenue à nos deux rapporteurs
Laurence Cohen et Laurence Rossignol
j'ai démarré la Réunion mais je n'étais
qu'à l'introduction donc vous n'avez
rien raté mesdames
que la journée commence très très bien
la journée commence très très bien
voilà merci au rapporteur
très bien
je vous laisse donc Madame et Monsieur
immédiatement intervenir sur les travaux
du H&E et les différentes questions que
j'ai pu vous poser puisque désormais que
nous sommes au complet nous sommes
toutes oui pour que vous nous parliez de
ces travaux et des angles notamment des
angles morts et des et des choses qui
n'auraient pas été traitées dans dans ce
que vous avez pu mener au H&M merci à
vous d'être là et à vous la parole merci
voilà merci de nous recevoir ça me
ferait plaisir d'être avec vous je vais
me présenter je m'appelle donc Gilles je
suis médecin généraliste je vais
décliner tout comme ça vous verrez mes
conflits d'intérêt je suis membre
militant associatif au collectif émises
contre le viol et SOS fan 93 je suis
enseignant à Sorbonne université et puis
je suis venu au conseil je l'étais de
2013 à 2019 et à nouveau depuis 2022
donc ça me permet un peu de rappeler que
le Conseil est constitué quand même de
membres qui sont
la totalité et bénévole donc ça c'est
important avec des faibles moyens et que
malgré ses faibles moyens le Conseil a
fait des des rapports dont près de 50%
des recommandations étaient reprises
dans des projets de loi ou même reprise
dans des dans des lois effectives je
vais juste reprendre avant de passer la
parole à la mettre d'oeuvre du dernier
rapport reprendre un petit peu les
rapports il y en a eu sur l'IVG en 2013
sur la PMA en 2015 sur l'éducation à la
sexualité et à l'égalité donc on pourra
en reparler ça fait partie des points
morts ou des points à développer la
santé des femmes en situation précarité
en 2017
les actes sexistes dans le suivi
gynécologique obstétrical en 2018
prendre en compte le sexe et le genre en
2020 c'est le rapport donc Catherine
Vidal va nous parler puisqu'elle en est
la Métro d'oeuvre et c'était important
je rappelle aussi les derniers travaux
sur le préservatif féminin c'est
important aussi d'en reparler ou les
derniers les derniers communiqués sur
l'IVG et la nécessité de
constitutionnaliser ce droit voilà
c'était important de vous dire que
pendant un certain temps le conseil
aussi a été en attente de nomination de
nouveaux membres et donc le travail a
tardé peut-être qu'on ne pourra pas
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
avez posées du fait des faibles au moyen
et peut-être aussi du fait de de ce
temps en tous les cas merci à vous je
vais laisser la parole à Catherine Vial
qui est vraiment la mettre d'oeuvre de
ce rapport et qui va nous donner un
éclairage éclairant sur sur ces travaux
merci Catherine merci beaucoup je crois
qu'il y a des personnes qui
voulaient vous interpeller non parce que
Madame faisait avant
[Rires]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et merci
beaucoup pour cette invitation
on va rentrer tout de suite dans le vif
du sujet puisque
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être sollicité par
le HCE pour rédiger ce rapport intitulé
prendre en compte le sexe et le genre
pour mieux soigner un enjeu de santé
publique
alors ce rapport en fait part d'un
constat qui est celui de la persistance
des inégalités sociales de santé entre
les femmes et les hommes qui conduisent
à des discriminations dans l'accès aux
soins et la prise en charge médicale
l'importance de ces questions à conduit
à certains nombres de pays surtout Nord
pays Européens du Nord et Amérique
Canada donc ces pays ont intégré déjà
depuis pas mal de temps la thématique
genre et santé dans les prends plan
stratégiques des institutions de
recherche et de médecine et dans les
politiques de santé publique or dans ce
domaine la France est en retard
alors l'objectif de ce rapport est donc
de montrer que la prise en compte du
genre alliée à celle du sexe est source
d'innovation dans la médecine la
recherche et les politiques de santé
et j'ajouterai que ce rapport à une
spécificité à savoir qu'il repose sur
une approche scientifique au niveau
international c'est-à-dire que nos
sources sont toutes extrêmement robustes
ce sont des sources qui viennent
d'articles de recherche publiées dans
des revues internationales donc avec des
comités de lecture les enquêtes
épidémiologiques que nous citons sont
elles aussi validées quant à la taille
de l'échantillon et les tests
statistiques et les publications en
question sont récentes elles datent de
moins de 10 ans donc ces points sont
extrêmement importants pour comprendre
l'évolution des connaissances dans ce
domaine alors première
notion très importante il faut faire la
distinction entre
différences et inégalité dans la santé
les différences de santé sont liées au
sexe biologique au caractéristiques
qui sont propres au mal et aux femelles
au niveau des gènes des cellules des
organes des hormones etc mais quant aux
inégalités celles-ci relève de facteurs
sociaux culturels et économiques dans
lesquelles le genre joue un rôle
prépondérant il y a en particulier les
représentations sociales qui sont liées
au genre féminins et masculins qui vont
influencer à la fois les attitudes des
patients et les attitudes des soignants
la précarité économique qui touche comme
vous le savez particulièrement les
femmes et aussi les violences et
agressions sexuelles dont elles sont les
premières victimes et donc c'est
l'interaction complexe de tous ces
facteurs biologiques environnement
social lié au genre qui est donc source
d'inégalités de santé entre les femmes
et les hommes et hélas source aussi de
discrimination dans l'accès le soin et
la prise en charge médicale donc voilà
tout ça c'est déjà bien posé on va
maintenant voir quelques exemples la
durée de vie bon on connaît bien le
sujet les femmes vivent en moyenne plus
longtemps que les hommes il y a
l'espérance de vie à la naissance
l'écart est d'environ 6 ans
79.3 pour les garçons 85.4 pour les
filles mais ce qui est important de
considérer c'est l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé c'est-à-dire sans aucune
limitation ou incapacité majeure et à ce
moment-là l'écart se réduit il est
seulement de 1 an et demi
64,4% pour pour les hommes et 65.9 pour
les femmes donc les femmes vivent plus
longtemps certes mais elles passent plus
d'années que en mauvaise santé alors
comprendre pourquoi n'est pas une mince
affaire il y a d'une part probablement
le rôle de la diagnostic tardif de une
pathologie et à nouveau les notions qui
relèvent de la précarité économique avec
renoncement aux soins et mauvaise
hygiène de vie
autre exemple emblématique les maladies
cardiovasculaires qui sont la première
cause de mortalité chez les femmes le
cancer du sein des cale à 8e ou de
dixième place selon les
enquêtes or les femmes
développent plus tard que les hommes des
maladies cardiovasculaires environ 10
ans plus tard alors on peut se poser
évidemment la question pourquoi donc on
a longtemps
favoriser l'hypothèse hormonale à savoir
que les hormones les estrogènes ont
effectivement un rôle vasoprotecteur par
rapport à
le dépôt de de plaques dans les artères
et l'idée étant que à la ménopause la
baisse des estrogènes rendrait les
femmes plus vulnérables
c'est un sujet compliqué parce que quand
on fait un traitement hormonal
substitutif celui-ci s'accompagne de
risques importants d'AVC et autre point
depuis 15 ans l'incidence de l'infarctus
a augmenté de 25% chez les femmes de
moins de 50 ans donc cela signifie que
le rôle attribué aux estrogènes n'est
pas suffisant par rapport à d'autres
facteurs de risques liés en particulier
au mode de vie et cela nous ouvre de
nouvelles pistes de recherche et parmi
ces pistes de recherche il y a tous les
travaux qui montrent qu'il existe dans
les pratiques hélas un biais dans les
diagnostics et l'accès aux soins
l'infarctus du myocarde en particulier
est sous diagnostiqué parce que
considérer à tort comme une maladie
uniquement masculine d'hommes stressés
au travail dans la cinquantaine
dans la réalité pratique et ça ce n'est
pas anecdotique cela a été constaté dans
de nombreux pays pour des mêmes
symptômes d'oppression dans la poitrine
se des femmes ont trois fois plus de
chance d'être attribué à des raisons
émotionnelles plutôt qu'à des troubles
cardiaques on note aussi un retard de
prise en charge des femmes par rapport
aux hommes à l'arrivée aux urgences en
cas de suspicion d'infarctus et il y a
aussi le fait que les femmes minimisent
les symptômes et appellent plus
tardivement les urgences c'est
différents points concernent de nombreux
pays on n'est pas simplement dans ce cas
français donc cela
illustre à quel point les normes
sociales et les stéréotypes liées aux
genres vont influer à la fois les
attitudes des médecins et des malades
autre point l'autisme qui touche trois
hommes pour une femme on ne connaît pas
l'origine de la différence de prévalence
entre les sexes mais ce qu'on sait c'est
très documenté qu'il y a un retard au
diagnostic chez les filles des enquêtes
peu importe sur des milliers d'enfants
montrent que ici aux États-Unis 37% des
cas sont étaient détectées en bas âge
contre seulement 18% des filles
orientaux mieux ça vaut évidemment et il
y a aussi donc le rôle des normes
sociales liés au genre à savoir que un
jeune enfant qui présente des
comportements de retrait sur soi de avec
un défaut d'interaction sociale chez une
fille on va qualifier ses attitudes de
timidité ou de réserves alors que chez
un garçon on va s'inquiéter en se disant
il y a peut-être un trouble de la
communication donc les symptômes sont
plus discrets chez les filles et donc
difficile à détecter par l'entourage et
le corps médical et les enseignants
autre point très illustratif également
très important la dépression qui touche
partout dans le monde deux fois plus les
femmes que les hommes on a longtemps
également mis en avant l'hypothèse
hormonale avec les femmes avec leur
changement d'humeur bien connu liés aux
menstruations grossesse ménopause etc et
dans l'état actuel de nos connaissances
il n'y a pas de démonstration
scientifique d'un rôle unique des
hormones par rapport à d'autres facteurs
pour expliquer les risques de dépression
en fait on a mis en évidence un rôle
très important de l'environnement
culturel social et économique des études
internationales en particulier portant
sur la dans l'exemple 200 pays montre
que plus le niveau socio-économique est
élevé plus l'écart entre les femmes et
les hommes dans la prévalence de la
dépression se réduit et une étude
réalisée en comparant les pays d'Europe
du Nord et d'Europe du Sud ou dans ces
derniers les traditions familiales la
dépendance économique le travail
domestique les violences sont
particulièrement plus présents et bien
tous ces facteurs montrent une
corrélation forte avec la prévalence des
troubles dépressifs donc cela veut dire
que le contexte socio-économique expose
davantage les femmes que les hommes au
risque de dépression
la maladie d'Alzheimer qui touche trois
femmes pour un homme bon l'origine de la
différence de prévalence et l'objet de
recherche importante il y a évidemment
la plus grande longévité des femmes mais
ce n'est pas le seul facteur responsable
de nombreux travaux ont montré que il
existe des facteurs d'ordre sociaux et
culturels à savoir précarité économique
niveau d'instruction faible et manque
d'exercices physiques qui sont des
facteurs de risque accrus pour la
maladie d'Alzheimer et ces différents
facteurs de risque touchent davantage
les femmes
encore un autre exemple celui-ci on en
parle enfin un peu plus qu'auparavant
l'endométriose il faut quand même voir
sur le plan historique que c'est dans
les années 90 qu'il y a eu un début de
reconnaissance de cette pathologie en
tant que atteinte organique par le corps
médical
et ce n'est seulement que en 19 en 2019
il y a eu un premier plan national sur
l'endométriose en France et en 2022
comme vous le savez on a un deuxième
plan qui a été lancé qui reconnaît
l'endométriose comme une maladie de
longue durée et on notera aussi que ce
n'est qu'en 2020 que on a intégré
l'endométriose au programme du deuxième
cycle des études médicales voyez le
temps de latence qu'il faut pour rendre
qu'il a fallu pour reconnaître cette
cette maladie et en plus c'est une des
premières causes d'arrêt de travail pour
les femmes en France
donc on l'expliquait par des évidemment
par une longue histoire qui vient du 18e
siècle avec le tabou des règles les
femmes considérées avec leur sexe
toujours
faible tous les femmes toujours
souffreteuses avec leurs problèmes
gynécologiques et autres et la plaine
des femmes face à ces questions
d'endométriose face n'a pas été pendant
trop longtemps elle a été complètement
occultée et parmi les recommandations du
HCE j'en parle d'ores et déjà parce que
on est en plein dans le sujet
il est vraiment important en particulier
d'abord de soutenir la recherche sur
cette pathologie qu'on comprend très mal
mais aussi organiser des formations
auprès des médecins du travail puisque
il y a la réalité de la la les arrêts de
travail qui sont majoritairement
beaucoup liés à et aussi il faut former
les infirmières scolaires qui elles ont
affaire aux jeunes filles et comme on le
sait tout le secteur médecine du travail
et médecine scolaire est extrêmement
déficient depuis pas mal de temps il
faut vraiment faire un effort dans ce
domaine là
l'ostéoporose ça c'est aussi un sujet
dont on ne parle pas assez
les fractures liées à l'ostéoporose
touche une femme sur trois et un homme
sur 5 bon et les conséquences ça veut
dire des handicaps avec des coûts
extrêmement importants
donc un tiers des factures des fractures
ostéoporétiques de la hanche concerne
les hommes or hélas l'ostéoporose est
trop souvent considéré comme une maladie
de femmes ménopausées et il y a un vrai
sous diagnostic des hommes vis-à-vis de
l'ostéoporose mais de toute façon les
femmes ne sont pas non plus suffisamment
suivies en ce qui concerne et traité
pour l'ostéoporose
on peut évoquer rapidement un sujet qui
a longtemps fait débat heureusement tout
tout va de mieux en mieux dans ce
domaine là la participation des femmes
et des hommes dans les essais cliniques
en fait tout part des années 50-60 avec
aux États-Unis l'essor de l'industrie
pharmaceutique ou les essais cliniques
ont commencé à être de plus en plus
nombreux et très développés et hélas ces
essais cliniques ont été émaillées par
deux énormes scandales Nathalie demiede
et le distilben avec les formations les
malformations des fœtus et des cancers
chez pour les pour les enfants et en
conséquence donc en 1977
la FDA l'Agence du Médicament américaine
elle est
décidé d'exclure les femmes en âge de
procréer des essais cliniques de face 1
et 2
et c'est seulement en 1993 que le
Congrès américain a fini par voter une
loi qui oblige d'inclure les femmes dans
les essais cliniques et aussi les
personnes de minorité ethnique et enfin
cette action donc importante de la part
du Congrès
a été possible parce que il y a eu une
dénonciation par les milieux féministes
américains dans le domaine de la santé
en particulier qui montrait que les
femmes étaient sous représentées dans
les essais cliniques et quelque part la
situation pouvait aussi s'expliquer
parce que le risque d'infarctus avant 70
ans était très faible et on
systématiquement dans les essais
cliniques il est très rare d'inclure des
patientes âgés à cause des problèmes de
corps morbidité et depuis une quinzaine
d'années dorénavant après tous ces
cette réalité de prise en charge des
femmes dans les essais cliniques il y a
une évolution très favorable du
pourcentage des femmes et par exemple en
ce qui concerne le cancer du poumon ou
elles étaient quasiment indemnes de
cancer du poumon auparavant l'inclusion
des femmes dans les essais cliniques est
passé de 33% en 90 à 48% en 2012 et
quand on regarde tous les chiffres qui
rassemblent dans le registre
international des essais cliniques qui
est tenu par l'OMS et le Naiche ou à
tous les essais cliniques doivent être
obligatoirement déclarer dans ce
registre international et quand on
regarde les chiffres d'inclusion des
femmes entre 2008 et 2018
toute pathologie confondues on voit que
l'inclusion des femmes est en moyenne
supérieure ou égale à 50%. alors cela
peut varier selon les années en fait ça
varie en fonction du type de une
pathologies qui est la plus étudiée à un
moment donné si il y a des pistes de
nouveau médicament pour contre le cancer
de la prostate il y aura plus d'hommes
dans l'ensemble des essais cliniques
c'est bien clair donc il faut vraiment
réaliser que on est plus dans les
situations antérieures de
sous-représentation des femmes
alors le sujet donc c'est un sujet
évidemment que vous connaissez très bien
les problèmes de la précarité des femmes
la précarité économique par rapport à
l'accès aux soins et à la prise en
charge médicale
j'irai rapidement vous connaissez le
sujet 70% des travailleurs pauvres sont
des femmes un tiers des familles
monoparentales c'est souvent les femmes
vivent sous le seuil de la pauvreté donc
cela entraîne un renoncement aux soins
une mauvaise hygiène de vie avec
et là c'est une alimentation
déséquilibrée consommation d'alcool
tabac c'est dansarité qui vont
contribuer à une dégradation de la santé
physique et mentale avec en particulier
des gros problèmes d'obésité diabète
maladie cardiovasculaires dépression etc
autre point qui n'est pas suffisamment
abordé les risques professionnels et la
pénibilité au travail les cancers
d'origine professionnelle sont souvent
sous évalués chez les femmes c'est en
particulier le cancer du poumon qui fait
l'objet de très peu d'études on notera
aussi que en ce qui concerne les agents
cancérogènes dans le secteur d'une
nettoyage dont on a souvent parlé mais
en l'occurrence on n'a pas d'études
épidémiologiques suffisamment solides
pour documenter ces questions là une
étude de l'Inserm a montré que il y
avait une augmentation de 26% du cancer
du sein lorsque le en cas de travail de
nuit et bien sûr il faut vraiment former
les tous les les entreprises à ces
questions là c'est extrêmement
fondamentales
on sait aussi que les troubles
musculo-squelettiques sont plus
fréquents chez les femmes à cause
justement de type d'activités avec des
métiers ou il y a des postures
répétitives inconfortables telles que à
nouveau le nettoyage l'aide à la
personne etc les risques psychosociaux
qui sont plus fréquents également chez
les femmes à cause de des postes peu
qualifiés horaires atypique parcours
professionnel en rupture etc et une
étude récente a montré que le risque de
basculement d'un mal-être d'ordre
psychosocial vers un trouble avéré de la
santé mentale va concerner 26% des
femmes et 19% des hommes
je reviens donc sur ces notions donc de
pénibilité aussi au travail donc un
point important est de réaliser que les
critères de reconnaissance des maladies
professionnelles sont majoritairement
fondées sur le travail fait masculin et
donc il est très difficile pour les
femmes de le faire reconnaître
la charge domestique et familiale avec
la double journée de travail évidemment
joue un rôle particulier sur la santé
physique et mentale et les violences on
n'a pas on ne parle pas suffisamment de
des cons
enfin on parle des violences beaucoup
évidemment pour la prévention et pour la
prise en charge des femmes qui en sont
victimes mais il y a l'aspect santé
mentale et santé physique qui doit être
aussi au même titre pris en charge de
façon vraiment volontaire
donc les conclusions de ce rapport
est que justement cette notion de
cette dimension du genre qui n'était pas
forcément très acquises auparavant cette
dimension du genre alliée à celle du
sexe a donc des retombées majeures en
termes de connaissances scientifique de
prise en charge médicale et de
traitement de prévention et
d'optimisation des coûts de santé et
donc cela va nous permettre de
construire des politiques de recherche
et de santé plus égalitaires pour les
femmes et pour les hommes et donc nous
avons en conclusion de ce rapport
il y a 40 recommandations avec 4
recommandations phares intégrer la
thématique genre et santé dans la
formation aux professions médicales et
paramédicales
formation initiale des étudiants qui est
encore très peu développé formation
continue des professionnels de santé et
tout cela doit aussi inclure une
formation de la du dépistage
systématique des violences
il serait bon également de créer une
nouvelle institution publique de
recherche et de médecine sur la
thématique genre et santé qui
permettrait de réaliser quelque chose
qui est toujours difficile à mettre en
oeuvre à savoir une approche
pluridisciplinaire sur ces questions là
qui pour permettrait donc d'associer les
recherches cliniques biomédicales avec
les recherches en sciences sociales et
en santé publique il faut évidemment
garantir l'accès aux soins pour les
femmes précaires et favoriser aussi la
parité dans l'accès au poste de
responsabilité dans les professions de
santé et de recherche merci beaucoup
pour votre attention
non vraiment merci à tous les deux pour
cette présentation à devoir une
présentation très étayée très renseignée
et très fouillé et je vais peut-être
dans un premier temps laisser la parole
au rapporteur qui souhaite vous
interroger j'imagine sur ces
conclusions du HSE ces propositions et
ce diagnostic est quand même assez
éloquant et puis bien entendu après je
passerai la parole aux autres sénatrices
qui le demandent où sénateur il y a pas
de sénateur ce matin dans la salle merci
donc tout d'abord Marie-Pierre Richer
merci présidente merci Madame Madame et
Monsieur pour pour vos propos je vais
revenir justement sur sur vos propos on
a évoqué les essais cliniques et vous
vous avez dit dans vos propos et c'est
dans le rapport qu'il y a une évolution
de prise en compte justement du genre et
que les inégalités se réduisent en vous
appuyant sur les travaux d'Amérique du
Nord
USA et vous madame vous avez dit dans
vos propos que la France a du retard en
la matière jusqu'à quel point la France
a du retard et comment elle s'inscrit
par rapport au pays européens
ensuite j'avais noté
dans l'une de vos recommandations et
puis vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
qu'il y ait une prise en compte de bout
en bout de certaines maladies des femmes
et j'ai lu dans la presse récemment que
l'Institut Curie d'encologie espère être
retenu dans le cadre du programme
d'investissement d'avenir afin
d'inventer la médecine de demain pour
une nouvelle structure entièrement
dédiée au cancer des femmes ça répond à
une des 40 de vos préconisations
avez-vous connaissance de la mise en
place d'autres projets
et puis
après c'est tout avec trois questions
votre rapport s'inscrit dans la lignée
si j'ai bien lu de ce de 2017 et 2018 et
dans le rapport vous parlez d'une clause
de revoyure au bout de deux ans nous
sommes au bout de deux ans qu'en est-il
et avez-vous d'autres travaux en
perspective merci
je préfère répondre à chaud
voilà comme je vous l'ai dit les essais
cliniques bon ça concerne une
institution
ça doit répondre aux critères des
institutions internationales
définies par l'OMS et le nai Edge et la
France en fait partie au même titre que
les autres pays et on n'a pas un retard
particulier dans les pratiques en France
la notion de retard de la France par
rapport à d'autres pays européens au
nord américain
c'est la notion de d'avoir des
institutions publiques de recherche et
des institutions médicales qui soient
dédié à l'intégration de la notion de
sexe et de genre dans les stratégies
des institutions de recherche et dans
les politiques publiques donc c'est dans
ce sens là c'est à dire une des actions
gouvernementales pour donner un statut à
ces questions là
en ce qui concerne maintenant les toutes
les recherches menées sur le cancer les
cancers qu'il y ait comme l'Institut
Curie est en train de le développer des
thématiques davantage dédiées au cancer
féminin on ne peut que s'en réjouir
voilà et quant aux aspects
suivis enfin comment est-ce que les
recommandations que nous avons faites
ont été prises en compte
on a là il y a deux ans de décalage par
rapport aux conclusions de l'époque si
on veut avoir une idée des retombées
bah pour cela il faut des financements
il faut des financements il faut mener
des enquêtes sur le terrain il faut
faire des des études épidémiologiques il
faut
il faut aller sur le terrain pour voir
que ce soit auprès des institutions de
recherche que ce soit chez les
praticiens que ce soit dans les
associations et cette démarche là
a priori elle doit se faire avec une
volonté délibérée de de
dresser un état des lieux des avancées
ou des recul sur ces questions
merci beaucoup donc je poursuis avec les
rapporteurs donc Annick Jacquemet
merci madame la présidente Madame
Monsieur Merci pour pour vos propos pour
ce travail que vous avez fait qui je
pense va bien nous éclairer déjà dans un
premier temps alors j'ai eu une autre
question vous parlez très peu du sport
si ce n'est quand vous abordez la
maladie d'Alzheimer ou vous dites qui a
effectivement un manque d'activité
physique mais on a vu qu'il y avait un
écart d'un an et demi entre les femmes
et les hommes pour vieillir en bonne
santé et d'autres pathologies aussi qui
sont liés au sport est-ce que vous vous
êtes intéressé justement à cette
activité physique dans le cadre de vos
travaux pour voir quel est l'impact
justement que ça pouvait avoir aussi les
écarts que vous annoncez pouvaient être
dur en partie à ce manque d'activité
physique et puis je serai intéressé
aussi à connaître les causes vous nous
disiez qu'il y avait une augmentation de
26% de cancer du sein en cas de travail
de nuit
savoir à quoi est-ce qu'on attribue
cette augmentation du cancer du sein
est-ce que c'est la fatigue est-ce que
c'est le décalage du cirque du cycle
circadien
voilà dans un premier temps les
questions que m'inspire vos propos merci
alors en ce qui concerne le sport
qui évidemment les activités sportives
sont extrêmement importantes pour rester
en bonne santé
nous ne l'avons pas évoqué précisément
dans dans le rapport comme vous l'avez
souligné
je dirais que sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres d'ailleurs
recueillir des données
est extrêmement difficile
parce que
quand on veut avoir des échantillons
représentatifs d'une certaine catégorie
de la population
les uns les unes faisant du sport et pas
les autres
constituer des groupes de personnes
homogènes c'est extrêmement difficile en
soi quel type d'activités sportives ou
quand comment les personnes ont-elles
des comorbidités qui feraient que la le
bénéfice du sport puisse être
enfin puisse varier
quels âges quelle tranche d'âge et
étudier oui la difficulté de mettre en
place simplement une enquête avec tous
les talents des gens qui font des
enquêtes
qu'on a nous en France ce genre d'études
est extrêmement difficile à réaliser
et et à nouveau il faut des financements
si on veut la réaliser donc on est on
est en manque de données là-dessus on a
des on peut avoir des des
espérer que des campagnes de permettront
de plus mobiliser les gens sur ces
questions là mais voyez mesurer et
regarder l'impact de des campagnes
d'information tout ça c'est très très
difficile par l'immense hétérogénéité du
sujet
en ce qui concerne le l'augmentation du
cancer du sein dans en cas de travail de
nuit
ça je
vaut mieux vous adresser à l'Institut
Curie
aux auteurs de ces études qui
certainement enfin ils ont fait une
étude justement très qui a permis
d'obtenir des chiffres avec des méthodes
rigoureuses mais quant à savoir
les raisons de de cette augmentation qui
est qui est constatée c'est certainement
comme on dit multi factorielle quand on
dit multifactorielle c'est on se cache
pas devant une ignorance c'est que c'est
vraiment multifactoriel et que arrivé à
démêler les différents facteurs c'est
quelque chose de de en soi extrêmement
difficile
sur l'activité des des jeunes filles ou
des femmes dans le sport on a
effectivement pas d'études scientifiques
mais on a quand même des études
sociologiques qui montrent que les
stéréotypes jouent un maximum et que
quand on analyse l'occupation des cours
d'école et les différents sports qui
sont réalisés par les jeunes par les
petites filles et par les petits garçons
on a quand même pas la même chose la
valorisation du sport chez les femmes
c'est quand même
récent et je crois que la manifestement
quand on revoit en plus les trois cadres
qui ont été présentés par les
stéréotypes les violences et la
précarité on comprend que là on a un
travail à faire pour améliorer la santé
des femmes et le sport en est un
donc je pense que vous avez répondu à
toutes les questions donc je poursuis
avec le tour de nos rapports avec la
rapporteurs Laurence Cohen merci madame
la Présidente merci Madame et Monsieur
pour pour ce rapport qui est extrêmement
riche simplement de manière anecdotique
sur le sport et les stéréotypes j'ai une
de mes petites filles qui est en
cinquième donc elle va avoir 12 ans et
elle m'a rapporté ce week-end que elle
voulait elle voulait jouer au foot et
que les garçons l'ont exclu du du jeu
elle a beaucoup de caractères donc bon
je dirais c'est pas laisser faire et
mais après y compris ils lui ont dit
mais tu as bien fait quand même tu vois
parce que finalement
elle a fini par les mépriser voilà s'en
sortir comme ça et ils lui ont dit mais
tu as eu raison finalement de pas venir
avec nous alors qu'elle était exclue au
départ parce que ça finit en jeu de
rugby et donc tu aurais pas pu c'était
pas dû c'était pas du foot c'était du
non mais c'est pour dire on est en
cinquième voilà moi je trouve comme
chaque fois vos rapports extrêmement
riches extrêmement fouillé et c'est une
source d'inspiration pour pour les
législateurs que que nous sommes et je
pense pour tous ceux qui sont attachés à
l'égalité au droit des femmes alors je
voudrais simplement vous poser la
question sur le fait que cette étude ce
rapport vous l'avez vous avez pu
l'envisager au niveau à la fois de
l'hexagone et des territoires
ultramarins où vous n'avez pas pu
pousser votre votre recherche à ce
niveau là parce que on sait que il y a
quand même des différences qui existent
en termes et au niveau social au niveau
économique etc mais ma collègue victoire
le sait bien mieux que que nous mais
nous sommes attachés à ce que ça soit
sur l'ensemble du territoire donc c'est
cette cette première question que je
voulais vous poser la deuxième question
c'est qu'effectivement
on voit bien que par rapport à tout ce
que vous avez ouvert à vos
recommandations etc que pour aller plus
loin il faut qu'il y ait une prise en
compte à mon avis gouvernementale qui va
poursuivre qui va amplifier qui va
compléter avec les moyens que que peut
avoir un gouvernement donc ma deuxième
question c'est est-ce que vous avez pu
le présenter à la ministre
Rome et qu'elle a été son son accueil et
quels engagements elle a pu ou voulu
prendre auprès auprès de vous et ma
troisième question c'est
c'est en lien avec le travail que nous
pourrions produire est-ce que vous
pensez que par rapport à ce que vous
avez déjà fait ressortir et qui est
extrêmement riche vous êtes un petit peu
frustré parce que il y aurait un angle
mort je ne le vois pas moi
personnellement l'angle mort mais comme
vous vous avez eu ce travail approfondi
peut-être que vous vous sentez qu'il y a
quelque chose que vous auriez aimé voir
développer davantage et que
malheureusement vous n'avez pas pu faire
donc je vous remercie par avance
alors en ce qui concerne les les
territoires ultramarins
on ne peut que constater un manque de de
recherche et d'études menées sur place
en lien avec toutes les questions que
j'ai pu évoquer
on sait bien que hélas les
moyens ne sont pas alloués
comme sur le territoire pour
essayer de
démêler de démêler un petit peu
justement ces questions liées à
l'environnement social culturel
économique et de le mettre en
perspective par rapport à la santé
donc c'est un effort qui doit
effectivement vraiment être fait les les
études internationales
sont très présentes aussi dans mon
rapport
c'est important à titre de comparaison
pour vraiment
montrer à quel point il n'y a pas
forcément des spécificités
franco-françaises
hexagonale que dans de nombreux pays en
tout cas dans des pays
plutôt nantis mais on a aussi des
problèmes de dépression dans les pays du
Sud donc voyez c'est tellement important
d'avoir des sources de de connaissances
qui soient très élargie
et parce que sinon on peut pas vraiment
se rendre compte des points qui vont
être les points majeurs à aborder
vraiment dans des mesures d'informations
et de prévention parce que ça c'est un
extrêmement important
et il faut pas faut vraiment toujours
s'intéresser à l'international pour
comparer
et ensuite ça va nous guider
en ce qui concerne maintenant la
portée de ce rapport
nous l'avons remis à Monsieur Véran et
Madame Moreno à l'époque en 2020
mais nous n'avons pas nous n'avons pas
jusqu'à présent d'entretien avec
l'équipe de Madame Rome
et quand aux angles morts
bon il y en a il y en a forcément c'est
à dire que dans ce rapport bon nous
n'avons pas
trop
accordé de place à tout ce qui concerne
la santé sexuelle et reproductive parce
que ces questions là avaient déjà été
l'objet de nombreux rapports
précédemment
et donc je laisserai la parole à Gilles
sur ces sur ces questions là c'est
évidemment un sujet extrêmement
important ce qui est très important
aussi c'est l'éducation
à la santé sexuelle
dans à l'école et dans de très
nombreuses endroits enfin l'éducation à
la santé sexuelle c'est c'est
fondamental et hélas en tout cas en
France c'est pas
c'est pas fait
merci beaucoup pour ces
différents rapports on les a présentés
aux différents ministres en 2007 en 2017
à tous les moments on les a présentés
est-ce qu'il y a eu des suites
depuis qu'on les a présentés il y a eu
quelques suites puisque des
recommandations ont été reprises dans
les lois mais évidemment pas toutes et
là si on reprend par exemple les quatre
recommandations phares sur la formation
initiale des étudiants en jean inventés
on n'a pas beaucoup d'études moi si je
regarde dans la fac où je travaille
effectivement il y a une petite
amélioration avec des enseignements sur
sur la prise en charge des femmes en
matière cardiovasculaire mais bon c'est
où quelques du des diplômes d'université
les étudiants qui font une spécialité en
cardiologie commence à être formée j'ai
interviewé quelques quelques collègues
d'hier mais j'ai pas vu vraiment un
grand vent donc là faut que vraiment on
accompagne et qu'on s'assure comme pour
les violences envers les femmes qu'on
s'assure que c'est réellement fait dans
les ces personnes dépendant et s'il y a
pas de questions d'internat aussi à pas
d'évaluation
réelle de ce qui se fait dans ces
facultés
ça mettra un temps fou on voit bien sur
les violences depuis l'étude en veille
bien évidemment aujourd'hui il y a des
recommandations de la SAS mais on sait
pertinemment que un grand nombre
d'étudiants ne reçoivent pas cette
formation donc là on a on a vraiment des
recommandations à suivre et pour les
suivre il faut des moyens encore une
fois j'ai commencé à parler du Haut
Conseil en disant que il n'y avait que
des bénévoles trois charges de mission
ce n'est pas suffisant et quand
j'interroge mes collègues aussi sur les
études en direction des femmes il y a un
manque de budget pour les problématiques
cardio-vasculaires très clairement donc
il faut vraiment que on s'assure que
c'est réalisé sur la formation médicale
continue c'est la même chose là aussi
pour tous les sujets importants comme
j'aurais senti violence ou inégalités
sociales de santé
les formations pour les professionnels
médicaux libéraux ces trois jours par an
point trois jours par an il y a
énormément d'indemnisés et c'est pas
obligatoire ça devrait l'être mais ça
l'est pas très clairement donc trois
jours par an c'est pas suffisant avec
l'ensemble des sujets donc là aussi soit
on veut améliorer l'accompagnement la
prise en charge de l'amitié de violence
lutter contre les inégalités sociales de
santé montré au médecin à quel point on
est pétri de stéréotypes quand
j'interroge mes collègues je leur dis
est-ce que tu as l'impression que tu
soignes de la même façon les femmes et
les hommes regarde évidemment et ben non
dans les fesses c'est pas vrai et on le
prouve et
la présentation et le compte de
Catherine lemonde très clairement il
faut déconstruire
donc pour déconstruire il va falloir
réellement créer une chaire nommer des
enseignants sur ces sujets participatif
là aussi sur les thèses j'ai essayé de
regarder les thèses sur les femmes on
commence à avoir sans 150 thèses de
bêtises général pardon ok ça bouge c'est
pas suffisant mais ça bouge sur Jean et
santé à part des études sur la
transidentité il y a rien sur non mais
c'est quand même incroyable il y a pas
grand chose donc là aussi s'il n'y a pas
une indication claire et ferme des
ministères de des universités de la
recherche de la santé pour s'assurer que
c'est mis en place ça ne se mettra pas
en place je reprends toujours l'exemple
dans les années 90 quand on a commencé à
mettre en place les traitements de
substitution par les patients
toxicomanes
rien n'était fait et à un moment donné
le mystère de la Santé a dit non on va
organiser à côté des formations
indemnisées des médecins on va organiser
d'autres formations qui étaient prises
en charge par le ministère de la Santé
la DGS pour permettre aux médecins de se
former et on a nommé des médecins qui
allaient dans toutes les provinces pour
former les autres collègues ok c'est des
démarches qui sont actives ou on ne dit
pas simplement fait mais on s'assure que
c'est réellement fait on met les moyens
pour que ça soit fait donc la chair
enjoressanté on l'attend toujours alors
sur l'accès aux soins des femmes
précaires là aussi quand on voit le nom
recours
comment dire aux prises en charge un par
les femmes et les hommes mais là en
l'occurrence les femmes quand on voit
que les femmes sont les premières
touchées par la précarité on doit
travailler sur le métier du travail on
l'avait déjà dit en 2017 les critères de
pénibilité ne sont pas adaptés aux
femmes les femmes sont par exemple comme
les autres très clairement et
aujourd'hui avec on a vu pendant le
covid l'aggravation de l'état de santé
des personnes de travailler dans le soin
et c'est essentiellement des femmes
la non prise en charge des transports
des temps de transport dans les journées
c'est quand même incroyable le
fractionnement du travail dans la
journée les troubles psychosociaux ne
sont toujours pas pris en charge comme
maladie professionnelle ou reconnu en
tant que tel là aussi la pénibilité et
les critères doivent être revus c'est
pas fait ça fait 2017 2002 on est 5 ans
après on y est toujours pas et alors
quand tu as parlé la parité ou de la
rémunération vous savez qu'on n'y est
pas encore donc là aussi s'il y a pas de
de comment dire de position
volontariste et puis de pénalité très
clairement financière envers toutes les
institutions ou les associations ou les
entreprises pour qu'il y ait égalité de
salaire ben on y arrivera pas et sur la
lutte contre les stéréotypes c'est un
peu long je m'excuse là aussi si on
reprend le rapport qu'on avait fait sur
l'éducation à la sexualité on voit
encore aujourd'hui
que près de 60% des établissements qui
ne mettent pas en place
ses actions donc si on veut que ça bouge
il faut que ça bouge et que ça bouge dès
le début et très tôt
j'ajouterai
qu'on peut quand même saluer
une initiative
qui est celle de
d'une personne
qui s'appelle Nathalie bajosse qui est
une chercheuse en
sociologie en santé qui a beaucoup
travaillé sur les questions santé
sexuelle et reproductive mais qui a créé
récemment un très gros groupe de de
recherche qui associe à la fois médecin
chercheur sociologiques épidémiologie
santé publique avec pour objectif donc
de d'étudier comment se forge les
inégalités de santé depuis la naissance
jusqu'à la sénescence
donc c'est un très beau projet il
s'appelle l'acronyme c'est jendi
gendhi enfin je parle dans le rapport et
en fait ce projet était financé par
l'Europe
donc l'Europe ce projet a été
sélectionné parmi plusieurs centaines
donc
cocorico on est très content que des
sommes importantes je crois c'est
environ 10 millions d'euros pour 6 ans a
été alloué à ce très beau programme de
recherche très ambitieux qui est déjà en
train de porter ses fruits parce que
grâce à ce financement on a pu financer
des étudiants pour faire des thèses
inviter des postes doctorants dans les
laboratoires
organisé des des collaborations
internationales des Colocs bon donc
c'est ce domaine de recherche là il est
superbement bien menée par toute
l'équipe de Nathalie Bajos mais c'est un
financement européen
et donc bon c'est mieux que rien mais on
aimerait bien qu'il y ait aussi au
niveau national des une mise en place de
d'une volonté réelle de soutenir
tout ce qui concerne enfin les
recherches je veux dire au sens très
large c'est pas
ce qui compte dans tous ces dans tous
ces questions on l'a bien vu c'est la
pluridisciplinarité c'est il faut
vraiment que les gens dialogue parce que
la santé c'est pas comme on le sait
seulement une affaire de biologie loin
de là c'est d'abord et avant tout une
affaire de société et
il faut vraiment faire qu'il y a un
effort qui vient de des instances
dirigeantes
sur la lutte contre les stéréotypes et
la prise en charge médicale
il a été annoncé que des cellules se
seraient mises en place au niveau des
universités pour lutter contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes
on n'a pas d'études aujourd'hui la
réelle mise en place ce serait bien
qu'on qu'on ait des informations parce
qu'on sait que dans un grand nombre de
facultés c'est toujours pas mis en place
et c'est important de savoir que la
lutte contre les stéréotypes elle est
importante aussi en médecine et je veux
juste vous donner quelques chiffres
d'une étude qui a été réalisée par deux
étudiantes sarahudin et Amélie Jouault
auprès de
2000 internes en médecine générale sur
l'ensemble de leurs études
ils ont été interrogés sur ce qu'il
pouvait vivre pendant leurs études et 60
40%
déclarent du harcèlement moral 18% du
harcèlement sexuel c'est un cinquième de
la promotion c'est quand même un
cinquième promotion 18% de harcèlement
sexuel 62% de discrimination notamment
majoritairement liée aux gens ou à
l'apparence donc c'est pour vous dire
que on a un travail important à faire
lors des études avec dans dans le cadre
des enseignants et des étudiants et que
ça forcément ça intervient aussi sur la
prise en charge des femmes et des femmes
victimes de violence et une des
premières études que j'avais dirigée de
slender qui avait amené la parution du
livre omerta c'était de montrer que les
étudiants vivaient des violences et des
discriminations qu'ils voyaient des
femmes victimes de violence et que bien
entendu la prise en charge n'était
absolument pas adéquate on est vraiment
dans un il faut qu'on travaille dans
tout dans tous ces champs et c'est
important que ces cellules se mettent en
place pour faire bouger les choses et
c'est vrai que on parle de féminisation
du corps médical et tant mieux mais
clairement encore une fois le nombre de
postes de pu où le nombre de chefs bien
sûr reste encore majoritairement
masculin et ça et ça c'est à c'est
important que ça bouge et je reviens sur
ces cellules de prise en charge des
violences sexistes et sexuelles si elles
ne se mettent pas en place on n'arrivera
pas à faire en sorte que dans ces
services ces ambiances sexistes et ces
agressions cessent donc c'est vraiment
important et quand elle la prise en
charge des patientes aussi s'améliorera
bien évidemment
merci beaucoup pour ces éléments de
réponse très complets je passe la parole
à la quatrième rapporteur Laurence
Rossignol
si madame la Présidente bonjour à vous
deux
moi je vais pas par rapport aux
questions composées mes collègues une
chose d'abord on a décidé de travailler
sur la question de la santé des femmes
mais on a bien conscience que on n'est
pas sur un sujet vierge et qu'avant nous
d'autres ont travaillé de manière
peut-être panique tu l'as dit dans la
dans un intro c'est ce que j'ai raté et
d'autres ont travaillé d'autres
travaillent aussi parallèlement puisque
l'Assemblée nationale de la délégation
aura des femmes à l'assemblée que vous
allez vous a peut-être déjà auditionné
ou qui veulent faire travail aussi sur
ce sujet
là c'est que depuis le rapport sur la
pornographie on adore les SCOOP on a
pris goût on a pris goût à l'exposition
médiatique et au fait de porter des
sujets qui sont dans
des angles morts ou des sujets
ignorés
et c'est pour ça je vais reposer un peu
peut-être autrement la même question que
Laurence qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui vous
semble ne pas avoir été encore
suffisamment étudié et qui soit
étudiable par nous parce qu'on n'est pas
on n'est pas un centre de recherche on
n'a pas d'échantillons sur lesquels on
puisse travailler en particulier dans la
dimension intersectionnelle des
questions de santé alors je suis appelé
la dimension intersectionnelle c'est
simplement le fait de des mécanismes
croisés c'est-à-dire voilà femme et
migrantes c'est un sujet intersectionnel
femme et handicap c'est un sujet
intersectionnel voilà qui sont pas
forcément sont pas des niches à mes yeux
c'est des dimensions du sujet je voulais
vous interroger sur deux questions
également qu'est-ce qui a été fait mes
collègues ont pensé que je ne lâche rien
et c'est vrai
voilà qu'est-ce qui a été fait étudier
sur Jean récentimental
aujourd'hui
et
deuxième question un petit peu plus de
cheese comment les questions genre sexe
et santé se percutent
vous comprenez Catherine
je
la repose autrement nous avons le sexe
nous avons le genre et le genre et le
sexe sont aujourd'hui dans des approches
dissociées comment toutes les questions
qu'on m'a toutes les questions autour de
transidentité voilà par exemple poser la
question simplement où est-ce qu'on
classe en matière de santé une personne
trans est-ce qu'elle est classée dans
son genre ou dans son sexe et comment on
étudie la médicalisation de la
transidentité aujourd'hui alors je suis
pas sûr qu'on ira sur ce sujet là c'est
parce que c'est
oui mais c'est dans le débat c'est dans
le débat
mais voilà c'est trop
de point de vue là tous les deux
là-dessus quand même même si on traite
pas le sujet mais moi j'ai une vraie
j'ai une dans les questions de santé
sexuelle et reproductive par exemple
ou en fait où on
identifie comment on identifie les
dissonances de sexe biologique de
naissance et de genre par la suite
désolé
donc sur les aspects
bon intersectionnel
à savoir essayer de
d'élargir la compréhension de de
certaines des problèmes de santé donc
dans un cadre non seulement
biologique mais social culturel
économique avec des données qui
permettent aussi
de mesurer de façon plus précise
justement ces aspects liés à
l'appartenance ethnique
aussi les questions liées au handicap
c'est à dire il faut qu'on arrive à
mener des études et puis démiologiques
des enquêtes sur le terrain qui puissent
intégrer tous ces différents paramètres
pour pour enrichir nos connaissances
c'est ce que c'est de faire le groupe de
Nathalie Bajos
avec justement
un rôle extrêmement important
des enquêtes démographiques économiques
qui vont
sociologiques qui vont être alliés
aux données médicales et aux données de
recherche biomédicales la clé elle est
là pour
c'est une approche pluridisciplinaire et
pour avoir cette approche
pluridisciplinaire et bien il faut sans
donner des moyens donc il faut
que les projets soient financés
les questionnements sont là sur le plan
intellectuel pour essayer de mieux
comprendre et faire avancer des choses
on passe rien sous silence mais encore
faut-il avoir les moyens de réaliser
tous ces travaux
bon la notion aussi de santé mentale bon
on sait à quel point la psychiatrie est
dans une
triste situation
la santé mentale bon moi en tant que
neurobiologie que j'ai aussi une petite
idée de ce que c'est
c'est un peu ce que j'évoquais
précédemment c'est la difficulté
de
mener des études avec des
critères qui permettent d'avoir des
données suffisamment robustes
avec un nouveau cette notion
d'échantillons homogène vous voyez quand
on fait des études il faut un
échantillon sur lequel on va travailler
et il faut un échantillon témoin de
personne qui
permettront la comparaison et puis aussi
il faut faire un suivi dans le temps
parce que la santé mentale c'est quelque
chose qui évolue enfin les autres
questions aussi enfin bon oui mettre en
oeuvre des études de cet ordre ça
demande d'énormes moyens alors j'ai
évoqué la question de la dépression
certes la dépression ça aussi c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement hétérogène
et c'est grâce
je dirais à des à des coopérations à des
études de
internationales qu'on pourra mieux
comprendre justement par exemple quand
j'insistais sur la les facteurs de
risque liés à la à la situation
socio-économique
quelque part c'est nouveau
qu'on est des données qui portent sur
des échantillons de milliers de
personnes
avec vraiment des des traitements
statistiques et des études magnifiques
qui justement ont
pris en compte la réalité de des modes
de vie des personnes et tenter de faire
des corrélations avec les dépressions
donc c'est si on prend que la santé
mentale que la dépression dans
l'incendie mentale déjà c'est
extrêmement difficile de de sortir de
quelque chose de solide
est-ce qu'on considère que le suicide
qu'on considère que le suicide est une
question de santé
oui d'accord par exemple en matière de
suicide est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'il y
a des analyses genrées sur le suicide
oui
alors aux États-Unis en particulier au
Canada aussi
il y a des études souvent très
contradictoires parce que
on aurait parfois tendance à associer
des pressions des pressions majeures bon
mais il y a aussi des cas de
schizophrénie des cas bipolaires qui
peuvent être associés ensuite à des
comportements suicidaires mais le
suicide ce n'est pas uniquement enfin
c'est là aussi c'est très hétérogène ce
n'est pas uniquement lié à une
pathologie mentale
et
il faut se faire il faut faire très
attention à pas assimiler les deux
bon ça c'est des spécialistes qui qui
débattent depuis pas mal de temps de ces
questions là
parce que justement on a de plus en plus
de données maintenant
quand on a peu de données en attendant
savoir des raisonnements un petit peu
réducteurs si je dis un petit peu simple
si nos connaissances s'enrichissent ça
devient plus complexe et là les nuances
peuvent se faire et c'est on progresse
dans nos connaissances c'est
c'est des sujets de toute façon
extrêmement compliqués
en ce qui concerne maintenant les
aspects des personnes avec
les notions de sexe de gens et de
transidentité
je reviens toujours à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure on a quasiment aucune
donnée sur
la
l'accès aux soins de ces personnes sur
des prises en charge médicale en
fonction de pathologies qui leur
seraient propres ou bien qui ne leur
sont pas forcément propres
on a très très peu de données et y
compris au niveau international donc
c'est quelque chose qui est à nouveau
parce que ces personnes c'est des
populations extrêmement diverses
donc
recueillir des données solides c'est
difficile et je pense qu'il nous faudra
du temps à
pour sortir quelque chose de
tout ça c'est en train de bouger et
bien sûr bon les
il y a bon moi je fais partie d'un
groupe international
qui s'appelle new rogendorings qui
s'intéresse à la à
tout ce qui les recherches en
neurosciences y compris en santé mentale
en lien avec le sexe et le genre et on
commence évidemment à s'intéresser à ces
questions de transidentité pour
essayer justement de de
favoriser des recherches dans ce domaine
là en donnant des bourses
des doctorats de pour des étudiants il
faut alimenter nos connaissances
sur ces questions là pour l'instant
c'est très ça reste très ponctuel
je répondrai pas à toutes les questions
[Rires]
juste une remarque sur famille grand et
violence on avait fait des études qui
montraient très clairement que les
femmes migrantes
subissaient plus de violence au pays
subissaient plus de violences sur le
trajet et encore plus de violence en
France avec des agresseurs
supplémentaires qui étaient les
hébergements bon donc il y a des études
sur la précarité là aussi on a plein
d'études qui montrent que la santé des
familles grandes est beaucoup beaucoup
moins bonne et que les programmes de
prévention ont encore une fois
s'adressent où ont un bénéfice plus
important chez les personnes qui ont
dans le moins besoin que sur les
personnes qui ont le plus besoin parce
que c'est ces campagnes de prévention ne
s'adressent pas à ces femmes avec les
bons outils les bons moyens et là on a
on a des problèmes de toujours cette
fameuse égalité
au fait la même chose pour tout le monde
non il faut pas faire la même chose pour
tout le monde encore une fois il faut de
les quitter il faut faire plus pour ceux
qui en ont plus besoin
et en l'occurrence quand on regarde le
suivi des femmes
en termes de prévention du cancer du col
de vaccination ou de mammographie on
s'aperçoit que les familles grandes ont
de moins bon à moins grand nombre de
dépistage et quand on regarde même les
enfants on s'aperçoit qu'ils ont aussi
ses enfants ses filles ont un grand
nombre de dépistage que des personnes
qui sont françaises depuis bien bien
plus longtemps sur la santé mentale à
travers l'étude qui a été montré par
Catherine et bien sûr il y aurait encore
beaucoup d'autres études à faire
il y a des déterminants de santé les
déterminants de santé sont très très
comment dire sont très nombreux alors la
santé ou l'action des médecins c'est une
chose mais l'action de la société c'est
encore plus et on sait pertinemment que
quand on a un travail quand on a un
logement quand on a
l'électricité par exemple ou quand on a
tous ces éléments là ça améliore
considérablement la santé des personnes
et là
si on se réfère à aux travaux qui
avaient été réalisés par le Conseil
encore une fois sur les femmes et sur
les métiers du soin on voit que sur tous
les métiers qui par exemple qui ont été
qui ont persisté pendant le confinement
du covid on voit que leur état de santé
c'est agrafé donc là aussi on a des
choses à faire en plus et puis voilà non
je répondrai pas à l'autre question
si beaucoup
on a d'autres demandes d'intervention
donc je vais passer la parole à
Marie-Pierre Monnier
et ensuite victoire jasmin merci madame
la Présidente merci pour cette exposé
c'est vraiment très très intéressant moi
j'aurais trois petites questions alors
d'abord vous avez parlé de diagnostic
tardif dans votre PowerPoint vous avez
surtout mis l'accins de certaines
pathologies sur l'autisme les maladies
cardiovasculaires et puis il y avait
autre chose dépression est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres maladies pour lesquelles ce
diagnostiquent est tardif et voilà ce
que vous avez travaillé dessus et
comment vous l'expliquer
vous avez parlé là dans votre
augmentation dans vos recommandations de
favoriser la parité d'un accès au poste
de responsabilité vous monsieur vous
avez dit d'une grande féminisation du
métier moi est-ce que vous avez des
chiffres c'est à dire combien de femmes
qui sont médecins parce qu'après
je pourrais vous les envoyer
au Conseil où on avait noté le nombre de
chefs de cliniques le nombre de pH et
ensuite le nombre de chefs de services
on pourra
dont vous parlez là du plafond de verre
en fin de l'accès au poste
responsabilité et dans la prise en
charge des femmes moi il me semble aussi
que les médecins généralistes se
féminisent donc il me semble que
justement on devrait arriver à pallier
la féminisation ne suffit par il faut
aussi qu'il y a une formation on ne sait
faire que ce qu'on nous a appris et si
on apprend pas on est aussi dans ce
cadre-là OK et après parmi toutes les
recommandations là on est en plein PLF
alors c'est un peu spécifique
c'est-à-dire que tout ce qui est de
l'ordre du règlementaire ne peut pas
être repris dans le PLF mais ce qui a
des augmentations importantes qui n'ont
pas encore été reprises puisque vous
avez dit que 50% étaient tout à l'heure
je sais pas si c'est à propos de rapport
qui pourrait être porté dans le PDF
merci
en ce qui concerne les diagnostics
tardifs
et bien
comme je l'ai évoqué en fait ça
s'explique d'une part par toutes les
stéréotypes et les représentations
sociales de ce que représente
précisément une maladie féminine par
rapport à une maladie masculine donc
tant que c'est cet obstacle lié au
stéréotypes sur les maladies perdures on
va continuer à dire ça c'est une maladie
d'hommes ça c'est une maladie de femme
donc
les deux exemples emblématiques c'est
les maladies cardiovasculaires sous
diagnostic chez les femmes et
l'ostéoporose sous diagnostic chez les
hommes
ces deux c'est deux types de pathologies
sont vraiment c'est au cœur de la santé
publique c'est c'est quelque chose la
prise en charge est extrêmement coûteuse
de ces deux types de
il faut vraiment
mettre l'accent bon
les pathologies mentales aussi enfin
faut vraiment mettre l'accent sous
comment faire vraiment pour réduire
aussi les coûts
de santé par rapport à
cibler des campagnes de prévention et
d'informations qui permettent de
réaliser
qui permet que la santé publique soit
mieux prise en charge et ça c'est ça
reste enfin à nouveau si une volonté
politique qui doit y avoir derrière
et l'autre bah oui ça c'est bon
je vais prendre la question de victoire
jasmin
merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente et merci
collègue donc je n'ai pas de choses à
ajouter sauf que nous avons la
présidente et moi-même rencontrer il y a
environ un mois et demi des femmes de
l'association de la police nationale il
a concernant les difficultés qu'elle
rencontre
c'est c'est lié à la non prise en compte
justement de l'Europe d'une part mais
aussi par rapport aux risques
professionnels liés à leur équipement
quelquefois ils ont des kilos
d'équipements et là vous avez parlé de
posture dans le milieu médical
paramédical et aussi par rapport à la
durée de certaines tâches qu'elles ont à
faire par exemple pour faire la planque
par exemple de pronom c'est facile pour
une femme qui est assez raide qui
s'ouvre d'endormir qui doit se changer
donc ils nous ont expliqué un petit peu
les dans la prise en compte de certaines
particularités de leur métier et en
matière de promotion le problème se pose
également concernant je remercie
Laurence Cohen pour la partie qui
concerne les outre-mer c'est vrai que
bon les budgets ne vous permettent pas
non plus trop de vous déplacer c'est
dommage mais
concernant l'activité physique et
sportive alors il y a l'activité
physiquement
dans le bénéfss mais pour la pratique
volontaire activité sportive nous avons
fait en 2018 je crois un rapport sur le
football la passivité du football par
les femmes nous avons vu qu'il y avait
de très grandes disparités dans la prise
en compte des femmes alors Laurence a
donné un exemple mais les équipements ne
sont pas forcément
fait et équipés pour les femmes
elles-mêmes par exemple les vestiaires
pour les femmes les femmes qui veulent
faire du sport du football par exemple
quelques fois ils ont complètement
exclues d'autres fois et réussissent
quand même mais n'ont pas d'espace pour
le entraînement elles n'ont pas de vesti
adaptés donc en fait la société a
construit un monde pour plus pour les
hommes que pour les femmes donc il y en
a qui réussissent à quand même et
réussir dans ce domaine là mais c'est
compliqué c'est très compliqué et dans
certaines recommandations de notre
rapport et nous avons cet nombre
d'éléments qui peuvent étayer ces
arguments voilà et la dernière chose
concernant les femmes qui sont en
précarité alors le lien avec les
dépressions alors l'alimentation
pourrait aussi contribuer j'ai eu
l'occasion de lire alors bon j'oublie le
document c'était mais que des femmes qui
avaient une approvision de la qualité de
leur alimentation et qui manquait de pro
ont été obligés quelquefois pour être
traité bien pris en compte par rapport
aux pathologies mentales d'avoir des
probiotiques pour compenser alors je ne
sais pas ce que ça vaut comme études
parce que j'avais lu ça comme ça dans un
dans un domaine dans un journal pardon
j'ai oublié lequel de quoi il s'agit
exactement mais je ne sais pas si il y a
un lien avec l'alimentation je sais pas
voilà merci
bon rapidement ce que vous soulignez sur
la la réalité de la la pénibilité au
travail des femmes dans la police
il faudrait voir qu'est-ce qui se fait
concrètement
enfin vous soulignez l'absence de prise
en compte c'est ce qu'on se dont on
parlait aussi par rapport aux maladies
professionnelles et la notion de
reconnaissance de maladie
professionnelle et sur c'est vraiment un
domaine où il faut vraiment faire un
gros effort
sur les aspects
activités sportives aussi enfin ce qui
est intéressant c'est que dans nos
discussions c'est tellement flagrant que
la santé c'est une question de société
et donc si c'est une question de société
c'est aussi une question économique et
une question politique et on en est là
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on est là
aujourd'hui ça fait plaisir
et votre dernière question alors là je
j'aurais beaucoup de réserves sachant
que quand on cite ce genre de choses il
faut avoir des sources
solide et fiable et donc tant qu'on a
passé source là on peut pas se prononcer
oui oui
il peut y avoir des troubles cognitifs
quand il y a des manques de vitamines
mais ça c'est vraiment prouvé la
vitamine B12 par exemple ou autre peut
mais vraiment voilà il y a des études
très précises sur des maladies
particulières mais je ne rentrerai pas
dans le cadre des prophéties parce que
moi j'ai absolument aucune étude
là-dessus je ne serai pas compétent
je voulais parce que le temps avant je
pense qu'on a quelques minutes c'est
tout oui je voulais je voulais
faire un autre point qui est proche déjà
vous dire que la commission santé du
Haut Conseil
excusez déjà aussi Emmanuel Piet qui n'a
pas pu être présente ça c'est important
rappelez que nos champs d'activité là
c'est l'évaluation des centres régionaux
de prise en charge de psychotrope
et on attend toujours d'un département
ultramarin qu'il prenne contact avec
nous pour nous dire ce qu'ils font par
exemple donc là aussi l'absence de
réponse nous peine
deux
on va essayer de faire un état des lieux
de la recherche sur la contraception
masculine et là clairement il y a pas
grand chose qui est fait il y a pas
grand chose qui avance et on se demande
pourquoi bah évidemment
on se demande pourquoi c'est comme c'est
comme sur les problèmes de de prise en
charge de la douleur des règles je sais
plus qui disait si les hommes avaient
des règles le problème serait réglé
depuis longtemps je pense que c'est vrai
troisième sujet c'est d'étudier aussi
il y a des réformes qui sont il y a des
lois qui sont essentielles par exemple
le remboursement à 100% des
contraceptifs pour les jeunes femmes
jusqu'à 25 ans voire la réalité de la
prescription gratuite et du
remboursement de ces de ces
prescriptions il y a quatrième il y a
quatrième il y a d'autres éléments que
je voulais aussi donc je voulais vous
faire part c'est que on demande toujours
le remboursement des préservatifs
féminins
remboursés pas les préservatifs
évidemment c'est quand même important
puisque ça permet quand même aux femmes
de d'imposer le préservatif et voilà
donc c'est quand même important et sur
l'IVG bien évidemment
les deux sont Issa aussi féminin c'est
aussi donc c'est vraiment c'est un outil
pour la femme elle peut le mettre une
heure avant les rapports c'est elle qui
donc c'est vraiment important mais c'est
toujours pas remboursé et puis sur l'IVG
bien évidemment la recommandation de la
d'inscrire dans la Constitution je crois
qu'on est tous d'accord il faut vraiment
qu'on y arrive et sur l'IMG aussi c'est
tout d'accord bon ben en tous les cas ça
fait partie des recommandations du Haut
Conseil et je pense que le danger qu'on
voit poindre dans nombreux États du
monde sur le droit des femmes à apporter
nous nous amène à penser que c'est une
sécurité obligatoire à mettre en place
et dernière chose sur l'IMG sur les
interruptions médicales de grossesse les
associations
et nous pensons que il faut faire
attention vous savez il peut y avoir des
IMG pour cause pétales et cause
maternelle pour les sociétales il y a un
jury avec un médecin du centre de du
diagnostic prénatal qui avec d'autres
avec d'autres professionnels vont juger
de
la réalisation de l'IMG et il y a des
causes maternelles et dans les causes
maternelles il peut y avoir un médecin
de la patiente il y a les causes de
détresse psychosociale il peut y avoir
un médecin désigné par la patiente il
peut y avoir un médecin gynécologue et
il y a aussi un médecin appartenant au
centre de diagnostic prénatal et là ça
pose problème puisque c'est pas les
causes prédatales qui sont en cause
c'est la détresse psychosociale de la
patiente et donc là peut-être qu'il
faudrait revoir le
du jury voilà je m'excuse d'avoir été
oui non non il y a un centre régional
qui a été qui est comment dire j'étais
accordé un financement pour un centre
régional de type trauma qui a été
accordé
dans un dans un département ultramarin
nous les convoquons pour pouvoir les
auditionner voir ce qui a été réellement
fait quelle est la situation et pour
l'instant on a toujours pas de réponse
voilà vous permettez une deux secondes
en fait bon je ne sais pas de territoire
il s'agit mais dans notre dans un
rapport de la délégation
des Outre-mer concernant les risques
naturels majeurs alors ce rapport date
de 2018
ça fait partie des préconisations que
nous avons faites nous avons demandé
qu'il y ait une vie réelle prise en
compte des psychotomas et récemment il y
a eu un premier président en juillet le
7 juillet 2022 parce qu'entre temps il y
a eu toute la pandémie et tout avec des
la dgom la direction générale des
Outre-mer donc service du ministère des
outre-mer et il y a eu il y a environ un
mois un autre bilan d'étape suite au
à la tempête Fiona qui a touché
essentiellement la Guadeloupe et là dans
la communauté de prise de la délégation
c'est
explicitement mentionné parce que c'est
une des demandes que j'ai renouvelé pour
qu'il y ait la prise en charge aussi qui
est un centre régional alors pour les
psychotromanes donc je ne sais pas par
contre quel département donc je vais
essayer de me renseigner je viendrai
vous voir pour qu'on essaie de d'obtenir
des informations
de la RSE de Guadeloupe que j'ai
rencontré il y a pas bien longtemps
merci très bien je suis un dernier point
pour dire quelque chose avant quand même
pour la première fois au congrès de
médecine générale France en mars il y
aura une séance plénière sur Jean et
santé voilà
oui je voulais
vous parler pour terminer quand même
d'un
des activités du groupe genre et
recherche en santé que je coanime avec
une collègue au sein du comité d'éthique
de l'Inserm donc ce groupe a été nous
l'avons créé en 2013 donc ça vous montre
quand même que sur le plan des des
questionnements de la recherche on a
fait pas mal progresser des choses en
fait depuis 2013 avec des rapports des
guides des recommandations pratiques
quand je parle de recherche c'est pas
uniquement recherche clinique
biomédicales c'est aussi sciences
humaines et sociales c'est au sens large
sur les questions santé publique etc
donc l'Inserm a organisé
en 2007 le premier grand colloque
international sur ces questions là donc
ça veut dire que la France quand même
commence à prendre un peu de place
nous avons aussi au comité d'éthique
fait des clips vidéos que je vous
recommande qui s'appelle Jean récenté à
tension aux clichés fait par des grands
professionnels qui sont très souvent
utilisés pour sensibiliser
non seulement le grand public mais enfin
dans dans différents réunions colloques
institution c'est ces petits clips
vidéos qui sont très très éloquents sont
utilisés donc il y a rares qu'un comité
d'éthique phase d'équipe vidéo en
général la comité d'éthique ça veut dire
gros rapports et notre dernier rapport
concerne je vous renvoie au site de
l'Inserm
concernent un problème dont il faudra
s'emparer sérieusement à savoir les
problèmes éthiques en l'occurrence
posées par les applications numériques
de suivi menstruel
à des fins de contraception et de
conception à savoir que il existe des
milliers de ces applications que l'on
trouve sur smartphone qui sont utilisés
par des centaines de millions de femmes
dans le monde
ces applications sont le fait de société
privée qui utilisent en fait la méthode
Ogino numérique pour prédire les dates
d'ovulation et les périodes de fertilité
des femmes donc on est vraiment face à
un gros problème à savoir qu'il n'y a
aucune fiabilité
dans les prédictions qui sont données
par ces applications et qu'il y a aussi
un énorme problème qui est celui de la
protection des données
qui sont renseignées sur ces
applications numériques donc on a deux
il y a deux sujets extrêmement
importants et comme ça concerne des
millions de femmes partout dans le monde
y compris dans les pays du Sud
je crois que il faudra un jour s'emparer
de vraiment de cette question
justement au niveau le plus haut
merci pour votre attention merci madame
monsieur pour ces interventions au titre
du H&E forcément elles vont éclairer les
quatre co-rapporteurs qui vous ont
interrogés ce matin sur la détermination
du sujet santé des femmes qui souhaitent
être
pris à bras le corps au cours de cette
session je on n'a pas identifié
totalement de
d'angle mort ou de niche mais peut-être
qu'il y a quand même des sujets qui
méritent qu'on s'y attels j'ai repéré
notamment santé des femmes et travail je
crois qu'il y a un sujet très très
important qui qui
apparaissait en filigrane j'ai aussi à
travers cela ça fera forcément écho à
santé des femmes famille monoparentales
je crois que c'est aussi travail famille
et dans le travail on voit organisation
du temps personnel du temps
professionnel du temps de trajet comme
vous l'avez évoqué
l'A le soin qui était un sujet que nous
avions également abordé dans famille
ruralité avec ce déficit de gynécologie
médicale et donc cette absence de
prévention de de traitement de et de
donc d'informations également les
inégalités socio-économiques sont
revenus souvent dans vos propos
liminaires avec l'impact que ça peut
avoir et donc à travers ces inégalités
économiques ont ça fait qu'aussi à santé
des femmes et travail évidemment et
organisation famille monoparentale donc
on voit tout ça s'articule un petit peu
et puis plusieurs fois vous avez
mentionné
la santé mentale la dépression et le
fait que ça touche je crois me souvenir
trois fois plus de femmes que deux fois
pardon on exagérons pas non plus mais je
ne suis pas du Sud donc je suis de
l'Ouest donc normalement j'ai pas cette
tendance à l'egger l'exagération donc la
dépression fait deux fois plus de femmes
donc il y a vraiment un sujet quand même
pour moi qui se dessine mais ça sera au
4 co rapporteur de de sens et de d'un
s'imprégner de cette audition pour
pouvoir cibler ce sujet mais
véritablement Santé Travail famille
monoparentales organisation
dans la société actuelle puisqu'on sait
aussi que les femmes sont plus souvent
dans des travail à temps partiel avec
des temps hachés qui rendent difficile
leur quotidien donc avec ce fil rouge de
la santé mentale qui avait été évoquée
par nos rapporteurs dans une première
réunion donc je pense qu'on va on va
avancer grâce à votre présentation de ce
matin les corps-à-porteurs vont à
avancer et je vous remercie sincèrement
pour cette présentation qui était à la
fois très très fournie mais en même
temps très facile en terme de de un
matin un jeudi matin de bonheur assez
facile à suivre avec cette présentation
très bien menée à deux voix je vous
remercie madame monsieur et on va
poursuivre nos travaux n'hésitera pas à
revenir vers la Commission du HSE qui
fait un travail toujours et très
inspirant aussi pour la délégation que
nous sommes voilà merci à vous bonne
journée merci